but anyway so that's that's one element
the other element within projects this
kind of as one of these cycles of hot
and cold topics full projects within
projects there's these cycles as well
and at the beginning of the project you
desperately trying to make people
interested and bring them on board and
you want them to buy into it and and
then if the project actually takes off
and you suddenly have a team of people
these are often quite influential people
and their people who without them you
can't make the project happen and and I
and that part of me I think that just
wants to control everything you know it
can't you can't control people you have
a team and things can get a little
chaotic and because we're all inter you
want a team okay and this is probably a
little bit of a controversial thing i
don't know but i've always been nervous
about i always remember reading this the
stuff about i'm not going to mention any
directors but a particular director who
would get his name as such and such film
and script by such and such and in fact
they were like 12 writers and so forth
and but i understand why he would do
that because if you've come up with
something that you feel it might not be
new but that you feel is really new okay
and you're only going to live for what
eighteen ninety years and you've got
this opportunity to reach the world you
know what I mean the public to a degree
what you want your name on it you know
this is me this isn't just a project
that I was part of a team of this is me
or maybe if it is a two or three if it's
genuinely being come up with and I've
known projects where there have been
three people who've come up with it and
then that's fine but most of my stuff
I've come up with the idea myself and
and it's been to me a unique expression
as I've already said so so I go into the
project and then with a couple of my
projects they've got very big what for
me is very big and people
common border influential and who I I
have to give them some creative freedom
and I have to give him some credit and
you have to navigate those choppy
markets carefully you have to navigate
that part of the project carefully it's
trying to maintain I remember there's
one particular project my opera project
I had some of you as a consultant the
financial consultant although I worked
on Wall Street I hadn't been on Wall
Street for years and so I got this guy
from barclays bank who agreed to be
financial consultant and in fact the
project ended up being sponsored by
barclays bank and supported by Plymouth
University so this opera it got to the
point where this guy from Barclays Bank
greg davies who's head of quantitative
and haverhill finance at barclays bank
he did so much you know he made it not
just technically and creatively but
emotionally possible for me to finish
this project and although to me in many
ways this opera open outcry is my
greatest thing I've done so far I had to
give him some credit i had and i ended
up changing it to open outcry originated
by alexis Kirk composed or created by
Alexis Kirk and and greg davies and of
course there's another side to this when
you tell someone earlier on in the
project that you're giving them a
co-creator credit they invest themselves
so much more into the project as well so
you get as what they put in more they
know they're going to get more
afterwards and so they put in more so
whether Greg would have done that anyway
I think he probably would have but in
general I haven't got to be careful i
say cuz it but I I find that when I give
people and I when I started doing
projects all right I was really it by
Alexis cope by Alexis co violates this
kirk and you still wear your sin when i
make videos my name's Lucas Kirk I
always brand myself but then a few years
in my red something the go give er a
book called the go giver and it said if
you give in bit
business you know that's the way to go
and also I follow spiritual principles I
try to live by spiritual fruit I try to
live by spiritual principles I fail
century I've sent at the time but key
spiritual principles trying to give out
and so this the go giver and the Iran
and so I started to say my pieces and
ice post-dated on some of the pieces i
did i post dated it i'd put by alexis
kirk and another person who contributed
a lot to it by alexis kirk and to other
people and that's sometimes I look at it
and I think I'll axis you came up with
the idea you know you were the heart of
this project and you've now gone and
given fifty percent of credit or third
sixty-six percent of credit to other
people but there's something in me that
tells me this is the way forward for me
because if I just so give try and just
make it an Alexis Kirk film and Alexa
skirt thing now I don't mind calling
Alexa skirt fell but I try and take
credit for everything I think it would
be like ever decreasing spirals you know
you need to even giving some I think
it's preferable to give someone too much
credit and too little that's my
philosophy at the moment that may change
but there you go
you